and please welcome maybe same as the
mayor of Cambridge who's gonna give us
welcome from Cambridge
good morning oh this is a very lively
group I'm I'm impressed i impressed
saturday 9 o'clock alright so my name is
Denise Simmons and I'm the mayor of one
incredible city and I want to those of
you that live here welcome and those of
you that may be visiting from other city
town or state thank you for coming to
Cambridge don't make it your last time
last time here because we're that little
city that does a lot of good and what we
here today what we're going to witness
we're going to participate in today it's
a part of doing some good so we gathered
here at MIT to launch a day-long event
that's asking us to focus on what kind
of future do we want to have what kind
of world do we want to leave for our
children our grandchildren our
great-grandchildren ultimately
ultimately we are focusing today's
program on the very survival of humanity
the very survival of humanity as we know
it so it's nothing too important you
know I say that with tongue firmly in
cheek because nothing can be more
important than taking the steps to
ensure humanity our ability to survive
to thrive decades and centuries to come
just recently we celebrated the 100th
anniversary of the hundred and fifty
anniversary of depends on how you count
with MIT of their presence in our state
and in our city and when you think back
and look forward and then you think in
this context you begin to worry just a
bit that will we be will MIT be here in
another
the 100 150 years so in order to have it
this this discussion around our humanity
and our longevity if you will I think
it's far important for us to recognize
that there are of course some variables
that are out of our control we have
known through influence over earthquakes
or where a natural disaster like a
hurricane or tornado might strike or may
sweep across the community or when our
illness or epidemic may rise up and say
claimed thousands we can try we can
though try to mitigate these events
certainly but we do not have say and
when they're going to descend upon us on
the other hand there most definitely are
things some things that we do have
control over perhaps the most important
of these things is the kind of weapons
that are allowed to be created to use
against one another you know centuries
ago those who waged war and built armies
had to take the fight to the enemy one
needed to actually be on the battlefield
in order to have a direct impact injure
or kill but as time progressed
technology advanced and became quite
adept at inventing ways to expand the
scope of war with each new generation we
became profession and in creating newer
and deadlier weapons and I don't know
about you but that really really worries
me when I look at the debates it really
really worries me to know that
you know in 2016 we have progressed to
the point where without ever having to
step foot on a traditional battlefield
the heads of states of numbers of
Nations had the capability of launching
weapons that could literally wipe out
swathes of humanity millions of lives
anywhere on the globe can be lost in a
matter of seconds that it's just a very
scary thought isn't it isn't it it is
and as we as we have good reason to be
afraid
if nation a has the power to completely
obliterate nation be the nation be just
may feel compelled to create its own
stockpile of weapons that can either
obliterate nation a just to act as a
deterrent but then nation c and nation B
become concerned that they may be more
vulnerable if they don't create their
own weapons and over time this leads to
dozens of nations each with the power to
completely obey the blue the Ray that's
innate its neighbors with each with
which leads to a whole level or higher
level of anxiety suspicion and I have to
tell you prayers that night that these
weapons will not ultimately be used so
what's the good news the good news is
that the ending of that story has yet to
be written just because we have nuclear
weapons doesn't mean we must use the
nuclear weapons and over the past decade
decades the nations with the largest
stockpiles of nuclear weapon we have
actually laid the groundwork for trying
to decrease the likelihood of these
getting used on one another we know that
there's an appetite for these types of
treaties and for our international
leaders to work together to degrease
decrease the nuclear stockpiles and to
open the lines of communication that
would hopefully defuse defuse tensions
before resorting to taking action
that could have a nightmarish effect and
consequences on our planet but this is
what's important the leaders of nations
across the planet need to continually be
pushed continually be pushed to keep the
conversation going forward and that push
comes from all of us
activities like what we're gathered here
to do today from countries and
communities all over the world and that
push must come from local government
that sends clear messages that we will
not be complicit in feeding the problem
by either divest by investing in
destructive technologies or any
companies that design and create these
weapons you know I have to say I'm proud
to live in this very little city that I
feel has a very great impact I know that
the council has been proactive in that
regard and I'm also mindful of something
we all should be mindful of that
Cambridge isn't going to save the world
that the City Council in mass peace
action and in folks like Emma here at
MIT all of us together can't save the
world by ourselves we can though we can
sound the alarm we can make gestures and
provide templates for others to follow
but it's going to take a prolonged
sustained action from people in this
community and all across the community
particularly those and in those
communities where military weaponry is
closely tied to the local economy to
make their voices heard loud and clear
so the message is we have to look around
here in this room ourselves and say how
can I be a stronger better ambassador
for peace but we also have to ask
ourselves who's not in this room and how
do we make them ambassadors for peace
each of us needs to be take on the
charge to bring other people into this
conversation and emboldened them to take
action because it's not going to be
think of every action as
a single drop all together we can make a
mighty waterfall it's important to
understand again that it's going to be
that prolonged sustained actions from
people from all of us across the
community to say one thing very loud and
very clear and that is not in our name
we need people we have to rise up and
demand that our money our intellectual
capital are not invested or used to
contribute to nuclear proliferation and
Cambridge can lead the way but it takes
a global village to follow in our
footsteps to make it feel real and make
the results lasting the people behind
today's events my good friend professor
King that you know I have to tell you he
is a very proactive very progressive and
a nudge I won't tell you how many phone
calls and now you're gonna be there this
is what you're gonna do in this stuff
you know you can't find anyone more
committed to Jonathan but he owes me big
for today but I have to say I said that
in joking but I'm not more proud or more
pleased to be here to be a part of this
work the people behind today's event are
going to share with you today their
ideas for just what that template looks
like I want to thank each of you all of
you to taking your time out of today's
schedule to listen to what we have to
say what is said and but most
importantly I want to leave you with
what I think is what joining together
will do we can Cambridge can we can all
make a difference we must make a
difference we can be the match that
sparks the revolution for future
generations so that they will live safer
more secure because of it so again thank
you each of you for thing for coming
thank you for the work that you're about
to do and thank you for the work that
you continue to
on behalf of MIT we're happy to have
here distinguished planetary scientist
and vice president for research I'll
just talk like this mayor first of all
thank you for those for those
inspirational words thank you for your
support of MIT and thank you for your
leadership in Cambridge on on this and
many many other issues so all the rest
of you welcome to MIT we're happy to
have you here we're thrilled to have you
here in fact in command-and-control the
chilling reconstruction of the history
of the nuclear era eric schlosser
summarizes the decades-long debate of
historians who questioned whether the
use of atomic bombs was needed to end
the Second World War the u.s. feared
massive American casualties in a Japan
invasion but Japan was already
devastated militarily and blockades of
the country's ports crippled the
country's economic function other
historians argued that the declaration
of war on Japan by the Soviet Union
would ultimately have had a greater
effect than detonation of atomic weapons
or failing that surely what atomic bomb
would have adequately made the point of
us superiority compelling as these
arguments are we really don't know how
history would have played out in a
different world war two endgame the
Soviet declaration of war occurred two
days after the hiroshima Cataclysm and
Nagasaki was bombed the next day
the day after that Minister of War kora
chika uh Nami urged the Japanese people
to fight on quote even though we have to
eat grass and chew dirt and lay in the
field
four days later Emperor Hirohito
overruled the military and submitted to
unconditional surrender for whatever
ambiguity exists at regarding the
original decision to drop those
devastating bombs the nuclear
proliferation in yield and numbers of
devices during the subsequent Cold War
leaves no such uncertainty of the
absolutely unacceptable human risks
thousands of bombs were built and
personnel were not adequately trained to
handle them safely or securely courtesy
of the Freedom of Information Act
knowledge has come into our keeping of
nuclear weapons involved in plane
crashes falling from planes into
residential areas catching on fire
incorrectly wired and armed by mistake
or by power surges there was epic
infighting between the military service
branches over the control of the nuclear
arsenal and documented evidence of
multiple services targeting the same
sites there were Strangelove Ian rogue
officers and idle threats of destruction
of cities I applaud Johnathan King and
the other organizers of this conference
and all of you in attendance for
bringing the danger of nuclear war front
and center so that these stories can be
told and strategies devised to help
assure that we avoid mistakes of the
past as noted in the workshop
announcement it's quite appropriate that
we hold this conference here at MIT
which has a rich history and ongoing
interest in the study of nuclear
disarmament let's also keep in mind that
MIT is home to an extensive program on
clear security and that investigation
investigators on both sides of the US
Iran nuclear agreement have MIT ties and
that using our reactor on campus in
concert with numerical simulation we
have faculty and research staff who are
designing more safe and more efficient
nuclear reactors and who are developing
plans for siting reactors on offshore
platforms and that we have alumni who
are designing tabletop reactors as a
source of clean energy and that some of
our prestigious climate scientists and
their colleagues at other institutions
are calling for increased use of nuclear
energy saying it is essential in order
to mitigate the most devastating
consequences of global warming I hope
that this matter in particular is
discussed in today's breakout session on
climate change in short the moral issues
that we face are abundant and the
critical objective of reducing the risk
of nuclear war she's ok ok
okay the moral issues that we face are
abundant and the critical objective of
reducing the risk of nuclear war cannot
be solved in isolation of the complex
web of other equally alarming worldwide
socio-political economic and
environmental problems the way to
proceed is to put the plethora of these
difficult problems on the table to
listen to all points of view and to
brainstorm practical solutions thank you
again for being here and on behalf of
MIT I wish you all a productive day
thank you so much professor
mayor Simmons good morning everybody
last year was the 70th anniversary of
the bombing of Hiroshima and Nagasaki it
was also the five-year review conference
of the signatory nations of the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty this treaty
signed in 1970 by the great majority of
the world's nations was a leap forward
in efforts to control nuclear weapons
and moved to a disarmament article six
states that the nations holding nuclear
weapons including United States Russia
France Britain China will proceed with
dispatch toward getting rid of them that
was signed in 1970 though the
signatories who didn't have nuclear
weapons most of them have kept their
promise and not developed nuclear
weapons those countries that had nuclear
weapons haven't made very much progress
as you can see leading into the United
Nations conference non-governmental
peace organizations from around the
world gathered in a New York at Cooper
Union for international peace and planet
conference with lead organizer Joe
Gerson is one of the organizers of this
event who will be speaking later to try
to nudge the official delegations
forward unfortunately there was not
great progress it was very very
disappointing
anyway a number of us gathered there in
New York realized we need to rebuild in
the US a kind of grassroots motion
calling for nuclear disarmament many in
this room are too young to remember the
nuclear weapons freeze campaign but in
the early 1980s support a million people
in Central Park and that drove President
Reagan to actually negotiate with the
Soviet Union and get the first
significant treaty treaty reductions now
in thinking about where it could be
Cambridge and MIT was a natural as
professor Zuber mentioned we have a long
tradition after the Manhattan Project
many of the physicists dispersed one
group came to MIT and they were among
the ones who thought it was a mistake
to continue to develop nuclear weapons
and they moved into opposition Philip
Morrison many of you read his column in
Scientific American for many many years
Viki Weisskopf Henry Kendall who found
the Union of Concerned Scientists Herman
Feshbach Randi forsberg wasn't actually
a physicist but she hung with the
physicist Bernard Feld it was the editor
of The Bulletin the Atomic Scientists
tossed incipits Aaron Bernstein who's
still with us and it will be speaking
today George origins who is a key
proponent of the architect of the
non-proliferation treaty and I haven't
mentioned the current group which Maria
mentioned for example Ernie Moniz our
former physics faculty who was a key
person in the Iran negotiations now it
wasn't only physicists other scientists
have played a role biological scientists
I think we were inspired most initially
by Linus Pauling great chemist and
biochemist who led the first major
nuclear armament effort in the United
States to ban atmospheric testing and my
colleagues in biology Salvador Luria and
signa David Baltimore chomskyan
linguistics George Wald and Ruth Hubbard
on the street were leaders in the
opposition to Vietnam war
hersh back meselson myself and others
worked on strengthening the biological
weapons convention so there's a long
long tradition here and we we are
gathered here or organizing committee
maybe I'll disperse so maybe I'll just
ask him to stand max tegmark Lance Gary
Joe one just end up coal so if there's
any problem Gary goldstein if there's
any problem look carefully at these
people now we wouldn't have been able to
do this special thanks to do to people
who are not here Patricia Wineman and
Christina English they're the staff of
MIT radius the former technology and
current and culture forum deals with
these broad issues supported by the
Episcopal Diocese of Massachusetts mass
Peace Action they're the the inheritor
of the nuclear freeze campaign than sane
and coal Harrison is this executive
director max tegmark when he's not a
professor of physics teaching a hundred
students in 801 is also the president of
the future of life Institute they've
been key in making this come come
forward and of course we've had the
support from from the city and from the
from the administration our organizers
have agreed there's one thing we did
agree on the president is the commander
in chief he came to office talking about
the importance of nuclear disarmament
he's actually reappeared in the last
couple of days talking about this we
have a petition
everybody has it in your packet we hope
many of you will sign that petition if
you do sign it
we'll send you an email later on with an
electronic link to send to your friends
your kids your colleagues and we're
gonna try to launch across the country
calls to President Obama to carry out
what he's to make the world free of
nuclear weapons
many people think that he is actually
very concerned about what his legacy
will be and that he actually might be
responsive to that okay that we're ready
for our first panel IRA if you would
come up here and thanks again to our